- Hey, what's up, y'all.
We're back and Seth Rogan is here with us.
Give it up for Seth.
(audience cheers)
So Seth's new book, Year
Book is full of epic stories.
And from time to time on the show,
we get guests with stories.
So epic, so long,
there's just not enough time to tell them.
That ends right now.
Today people, you're here for this.
You're welcome.
It's time for a new segment
called Epic Story Time.
♪ Epic story time ♪
The deal is I asked one question,
and Seth has a whole segment,
and a bunch of illustrations
to tell a story.
I'm sure I'll have some follow-up
questions at the end, Seth
So, but here we go.
Here's my one question.
Hey, Seth, it's almost summer.
Did you go to camp as a kid?
(Seth laughs)
- I did go to summer camp,
as a kid, Kelly Clarkson.
(Seth and Kelly laugh)
And yes, I went to Jewish summer camp.
I'm a Jewish person.
A lot of Jews,
go to a summer camp.
And at my particular summer camp,
something to note, is that the
counselors were very young.
The campers were around, you
know, between nine and 15.
And the counselors were between like 17
and 20, maybe 19.
So it's kinda like leaving
your dog in the care of a bird.
They were not very responsible, basically.
So every summer we would do
what was called a Teyule,
which was an overnight camping
trip away from the camp.
And this time we were going to
hike the Juan de Fuca trail,
which is a 29 mile hike,
over the course of three
days and camp along the way.
And the hike runs along
the mountainous coast of
of Vancouver Island, which
is in British Columbia.
Exactly halfway through
the second day of the hike,
so 14 miles into this hike,
a girl in our group
fell
and twisted her ankle severely,
to the point that she
passed out unconscious.
So we're like
15,
15 year olds with,
around three 17 and 18 year
olds who are our counselors,
now dealing with this,
they don't know what to do.
We don't have cell phones at this point.
They don't exist yet.
So someone hands me an ax
and tells me to chop down a tree
so we could start
constructing a stretcher.
Meanwhile, we're getting
cold and it's pouring rain,
and the sun is starting to set.
So all the girls in the group
start burning their tampons
because it's the only flammable dry thing.
we have to create a fire.
We finally make a
stretcher, me and my friend,
and we load this girl onto it.
And the plan is to carry her 14 miles
back to where we started.
After around three steps,
our stretcher breaks.
And we dropped of this
poor girl in the mud.
And we arguably make
her physical situation
much, much, much worse.
At point I'm handed a signal flare,
which means things are getting bad.
Once flares are coming out,
you know you're in a bad situation.
We were standing on the coast
and I was excited to use the flare.
And I saw a boat in the distance
and I pulled it and the
flare literally went one foot
and then fizzled down into the ocean.
So that was not how we
were going to be rescued.
Eventually, thank God,
three firemen, who happened
to be hiking the same trail,
found us and brought us to a
logging road that was nearby.
The problem was there was 15 of us
and they had no way to
get all of us to safety.
Some kids were getting
hypothermia at this point.
We'd been missing for quite a while.
- What?
- Though we, me and one other guy,
and one of the fire men
went to a parking lot to start a big fire,
so all the kids could get warm
that were nearby.
But this fire man was very
inexperienced and young,
again, almost in our age,
maybe his early twenties
and as he was lightening it,
the gas can he was lighting it
with itself, caught on fire.
And I had to kick it
across this parking lot,
essentially engulfing this
entire parking lot in flames
Eventually,
we were rescued.
We went to the firehouse nearby
on this little town of Vancouver Island.
They gave us wool blankets
and soup and things like that.
And honestly, I saw one
of my counselors recently
and I told him that this
story was in the book
and I always viewed it
as such a funny story,
did he view it the same way,
to which he said that was the
worst day of my entire life.
There's absolutely nothing
funny about that story.
I've never been more scared of
anything ever than that day.
(Seth laughs)
So we remember it differently,
but in my head it was
hilarious, delightful event.
(Seth and Kelly laugh)
- What?
Okay, wait, I had so
many questions during it,
but I didn't want to interject.
Okay, here's my big question.
When is this movie being made?
- Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know if Lost Jews
in the Woods, is yeah,
coming out anytime soon.
But maybe.
- Well maybe, don't go with that title.
But I'm just saying, I
would watch this movie.
- From the people who brought
you 40 year old Virgin.
It's a very,
it's a similar title.
(Seth and Kelly laugh)
- I just love it.
It's like everything kept
going wrong in every..
- Oh yeah, we were on the news.
It was a...
- Oh my gosh.
First of all, here's another question.
How awesome did you feel
that they handed the ax
to you to chop down tree?
- I felt good.
I was just a big kid.
And I think with kids,
you associate size with
intelligence, sometimes.
Like I was, I,
I was large.
and so I think someone was like
he's must be the most
capable in this situation,
but that was not true, at all.
(Seth and Kelly laugh)
- Oh my gosh.
Well, I want to say thank you to Marcel.
He's on our staff.
He actually did those illustrations.
Those were amazing.
- They're amazing.
Thank you.
- Way to go, Marcel.
I love you.
Well, Seth Rogan, everybody
his new book is called
Yearbook and it's out now.